hey what's up guys obviously with
comic-con just happening this past
weekend and the new crazy venom trailer
that was shown there is a lot of hype
going around right now about venom with
that hype comes a lot of questions
surrounding the film one of them is will
venom be rated R that's a question we
don't have an answer to yet and before
we got a real trailer as in one that
actually had been a minute
everyone was kind of worried that they
were gonna nerf then I'm a little bit
kind of make him not as bad and brutal
as he is in the comics and just sort of
toned him down a little bit kind of like
I did in spider-man 3 and I'm not
dogging on spider-man 3 but venom didn't
bite anyone's head off in spider-man 3
didn't we get our first actual trailer
that shows venom and I was blown away I
thought it was amazing I thought venom
looked great I thought the way that the
graphics and the animation worked looked
really good as well but even with this
trailer there was still questions on how
nerfed will it be will it be dark will
it be violent will it portray venom the
way that he actually is or will they
tone it down from the movie questions
that we still had after the trailer came
out but then this weekend at San Diego
Comic Con they showed us a new trailer
and those who watch the trailer said it
was not a disappointment in fact the
trailer was probably the most talked
about thing in San Diego Comic Con
despite the fact that Aquaman trailer
came out Shazam trailer came out there
was footage of Wonder Woman 1984 that
came out and Marvel didn't really have a
big presence there but still with their
partners Sony managed to have a movie
that was the most talked about and
that's because of what was actually
shown in the footage that they showed at
comic-con
they showed venom biting people's heads
off they showed his hands turning into
axes and him cutting bad guys down and
they showed him separating from Tom
Hardy or Eddie Brock and standing in
front of them and talking to him the
footage really just showed what everyone
was worried about and it gave us the
answer and we were all relieved but now
I guess people are worried that Tom
Hardy's not going to do a good job and
worried that Eddie Brock's not going to
be as he's supposed to be
he's not supposed to be a hero and
people are worried that he's somehow
going to turn into a hero but have no
fear director Ruben Fleischer has now
commented on the matter not only
answering our questions about venom and
how true it'll stick to the comics but
also answering our questions that we had
about Tom Hardy and Eddie Brock in an
interview when it was brought up that
many fans were concerned about how Eddie
Brock will be portrayed and whether or
not the villain were undergoing a heroic
transformation Ruben explained that the
movie actually lacks what could be
described as a real hero and he talked
more about its unique tone in the
interview he said I was really excited
about just bringing something new to the
genre I feel like the tone of our movie
is really original and distinctive which
is totally appropriate for the character
as venom is a darker more violent more
menacing character I think our movie
feels distinctive from a lot of other
superhero movies in part because there's
no real hero in it he continues to say
so it's just a movie that kind of stands
on its own led by incredible
performances by fine actors such as Tom
Hardy and Riz Ahmed but Tom really just
is I think people are going to be blown
away by what he brings to the table with
both Eddie Brock and venom his
performance is incredible and sets the
bar for the film so based off of what
Ruben said and based off the description
of the trailer that was shown at San
Diego Comic Con this past weekend and
based off of the trailers that I've
already seen I feel pretty confident
about venom but how do you all feel
after learning all of this information
does it make you feel better and more
excited to see venom when it comes out
or are you still worried about Tom Hardy
playing Eddie Brock and how they'll
portray venom let me know your thoughts
in the comments below and if you could
hit that like button before you leave
and be sure to subscribe to my channel
so you can stay up to date on everything
related to venom Marvel DC and
everything superhero thank you so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
you